i think if you want to talk about
recession nervousness uh you should look
uh at today's jobs report uh numbers
like this are just very much
inconsistent with uh
any kind of a recession call well you
know we have we're not denying that we
have work to do on inflation i know
times are tough
prices are too high
families are facing the cost of living
crunch but today's economic news
confirms the fact that my economic plan
is moving this country in a better
direction
let's look at the numbers the june jobs
report 372 thousand jobs added
unemployment staying steady at 3.6
percent
wages are up 5.1 percent but not even
close to keeping up with inflation with
that let's bring in our panel ben
dominic editor of thetransom.com and
host of the ben dominic podcast on fox
news radio leslie marshall democratic
strategist and jeff mason white house
correspondent for reuters since you're
on the north lawn jeff let's start with
you the state of the american economy
four months ahead of midterm election
day
well mike the labor market is strong and
that's certainly something that they
emphasize today from the white house and
and from the administration but as as
the president said in the clip that you
played that doesn't mean they don't
think there's work to do as we've
discussed before inflation is is
obviously very high and americans are
feeling that but the the advantage i
guess of the labor market being strong
is that if there is a reception a
recession it could mean that it would be
a mild one
on the other hand it could also will
likely mean that the fed will will have
a pretty hefty uh rate hike coming up so
there are pros and cons to that but
at least they see some glimmers of hope
here uh today leslie you're outside the
beltway what's the feel in terms of the
american economy
on the west coast
well not just on the west coast and not
just here on the left side of things
with my party people like seeing gas
prices come down as they have been for
days now people like seeing unemployment
low and staying steady and people like
seeing job creation and jobs report
better than it's been i'm hoping that's
going to transcend to some higher
approval ratings for the president
because all the american people see is
doom and gloom in the headlines
especially when it comes to the words
recession or inflation that still scares
them we're not out of the scary waters
yet but this is definitely good news and
i say that as a pessimist ben solid jobs
number but inflation's pretty brutal
your thoughts i think that there's very
little hope for the democratic coalition
to change the narrative
as people look at the situation around
the country
there's much more reason to be
pessimistic in this moment than there is
to be optimistic about the direction of
the economy and i don't think that
you're going to see any of that change
in time to further democratic hopes in
november
also today the president signing an
executive order on abortion he vented
his frustration with the supreme court
let's play it
the truth is today's supreme court
majority
that is playing fast and loose with the
facts i'm asking the justice department
that much like they did in the civil
rights area to do something
do everything in their power to protect
these women seeking to invoke their
rights
jeff is that just frustration from the
president since he really doesn't have
control over the supreme court yeah i
think there's a lot of frustration there
because of what you just said mike and
and broadly because he can't actually do
that much with executive orders on the
issue of abortion uh he issued the one
that we that you were just referring to
uh it does a few things it seeks to
protect access to abortions and to
contraception uh for women but the truth
is he just he doesn't have that much
authority to do that that authority is
now with the states leslie there have
been calls from the left for the
president to do something on abortion
rights is it enough
well it's not enough but he doesn't have
the power to do enough or to do more uh
certainly this is uh going to appease
some but it it's not enough it's very
scary when you heard kevin mccarthy
yesterday uh you know touching upon a
federal ban which we think republicans
will do if they get the house the senate
and the white house uh and not in the
midterms but in the general election and
of course there's a concern about
republicans uh trying to limit the
ability for women to travel interstate
even though that's currently protected
that could always be changed roe v wade
was protected and there since 1973
president's doing the best that he can
what the american people need to do if
they don't like this decision is get out
and vote in november and vote for people
that want to protect a woman's
reproductive rights ben what about that
does that energize democrats in
november's midterm elections
unfortunately virtually anybody on the
democratic side who was going to be
energized by this type of of rhetoric
was already going to be voting anyway
this is not a situation where you're
going to see some kind of explosive turn
around for them and a big part of that
has to do with the frankly extreme
position that the democratic party
occupies on this issue when you're
talking about
a nine-month spread when you're talking
about this sort of level of support for
abortion including taxpayer funding
that's something that just has not been
a major popular point for them
for some time now and i think that
joe biden and his party are running
right into the teeth of that
because it turns out that roe v wade
despite being framed as something that
was settled and popular and the like in
a lot of the media framing and the polls
over the years has not turned out to be
that popular and will not turn out and
from my perspective to be something that
changes the dynamic headed
into the midterms all right there'll be
plenty more debate about this issue
going into the fall but now it's time
for a moment in the show our viewers
look forward to winners and losers jeff
why don't you lead us off all right for
winners uh for the week i picked john
mccain the late senator and the other uh
people yesterday who received the medal
of freedom from president biden in a in
a very emotional uh and touching
ceremony and for loser of the week elon
musk and very possibly the the
shareholders of twitter after he said
tonight uh that he was pulling out of
his deal to buy uh that social media
company all right leslie your turn
i'm gonna go loser first marjorie taylor
green for once again being insensitive
to victims and victims families when she
is alluding to the highland park
shooting shooting as being a false flag
and winners well i'm going to say my
state and the governor of my state gavin
newsom is going to make insulin
affordable to those who need it all
right ben bring us home
boris johnson is my loser for this week
really a disappointment in terms of his
tenure as prime minister
though it is rather ridiculous as
mccauley told us to see the british
people go through a moralistic fit now
in the end
and then my winner for the week is
actually flo ryda and the folks at
fox and friends this morning put on an
incredible performance and included a
wonderful image of steve ducey dancing
along
to this it was just a good a good
enjoyable way to end what has been a
tough week panel thanks so much have a
beautiful weekend
hi i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now